the total credit cards in this country
have hit one trillion dollars of
balances in the middle of covet after
the stimulus checks route it was only
650 only 650 to 700 billion dollars all
those things come together and we
suddenly have the upswing of home prices
upswing of mortgage interest rates
and
this crazy stat the demand survey came
out
and for the people that bought a home in
2022 or the first quarter of 2023
62 percent of those buyers at least one
payment was either missed or they had to
use savings account in other words their
paycheck and what they were earning and
what that cost them to live was not
enough they had to dip into savings to
make up the Gap and make the mortgage
payment which is usually the largest
payment that they have in in their
budget